INTRO:
10 years ago, Supercell was just about to
release Clash of Clans.
They didn’t know it at the time, but Clash
of Clans would become one of the most popular
mobile games of all time.
They would follow up Clash of Clans with Boom
Beach, Clash Royale, and Brawl Stars.
And before you knew it, Supercell became one
of the most recognizable game developers in
the world.
And it wasn’t long until they started hosting
tournaments and handing out massive prizes.
Despite this roaring start, over the past
few years, Supercell has lost much of the
momentum that they once had.
Most of their games have lost the vast majority
of their interest.
And we’re not talking about declines of
40-50%.
We’re talking about declines of over 80%.
Clash of Clans, for example, only pulls in
5% of interest that it once used to.
Similarly, Boom Beach only pulls in 4% of
the interest that it once used to.
A similar story can be seen with Clash Royale
as well.
The only major Supercell game that hasn’t
suffered such a decline is Brawl Stars, but
even Brawl Stars is experiencing quite a significant
decline.
On top of this, many of the new games from
Supercell like Rush Wars and Hay Day Pop were
outright shutdown due to concerns regarding
longevity.
And as for the games that haven’t been shutdown,
well it’s not much better for them either.
Take Supercell’s latest game, Everdale,
for example.
The interest in Everdale is so low that you
can’t even see its graph relative to Clash
of Clans.
It’s not just Google trends that’s showing
this trend either.
Socialblade paints a very similar picture.
Most of our favorite Clash YouTubers are only
getting a fraction of the views and subscribers
that they once got.
In the past 3 years, Chief Pat’s subscriber
count has only increased from 2.51 million
to 2.57 million.
His viewership isn’t that much better either,
he’s only getting a few hundred thousand
views per month.
Back in his hayday, he would get more views
on each video.
A similar story can be seen with Molt, Galadon,
NickatNyte, ClashWithAsh, and so many more.
Now, I’m 100% sure that there’s gonna
be comments down below that claim that Supercell’s
games aren’t dead and that they still have
large player bases.
But, honestly most of these players are super
fans or they do it as a job.
Virtually all of Supercell’s casual base
has ditched their games.
So, while some of their games still have a
decent number of players, there’s no question
that Supercell is not nearly as popular as
they once used to be.
So, what happened to Supercell?
PAY TO WIN:
One of the primary factors that made Supercell
games so popular in the first place was their
unique mode of monetization.
Supercell didn’t charge users directly to
play the game.
In fact, you didn’t even have to pay them
a single dime if you didn’t want to.
Rather, Supercell made all their money from
people who wanted to advance faster.
If you didn’t want to spend years maxing
out your clash of clans base or collecting
a bunch of clash royale cards, you could spend
money to speed up these processes.
This unique revenue stream allowed Supercell
to create quite ambitious games.
Up until the release of Clash of Clans, virtually
all mobile games were extremely simple and
rudimentary.
We had games like Temple Run, Fruit Ninja,
and Angry Birds.
Given the limited revenue from these games,
developers weren’t able to spend that much
on development.
But, with Clash of Clans, individual users
were spending hundreds if not thousands of
dollars on the game which allowed Supercell
to splurge on development.
This gave casual players an experience that
they couldn’t find anywhere else.
No free game mobile or otherwise stacked up
to the quality and experience of Clash of
Clans.
Aside from being extremely accessible to casual
players, casual players felt like they could
do well in the game without spending any money
on it.
Sure, they might not become a top player in
the world, but it was realistic for them to
max out their bases within a few years.
With time, however, we saw updates that made
this more and more difficult.
A perfect example of this is wall upgrades.
To max out walls, you had to spend 4 million
gold per wall unit.
Only people who played clash of clans know
how big of pain this was.
For the rest of you, I’ll put it in dollar
terms.
To max out your clash of clans base, it cost
$11,000.
And out of this, nearly $5,000 would go towards
simply maxing out walls.
In other words, nearly half the game was simply
maxing out walls.
I don’t think I need to explain why this
made the game extremely tedious and frustrating
especially for late stage players.
And honestly, the only reason Supercell made
it so hard to max out walls is because they
knew that the top players were willing to
spend whatever it took to max out their bases.
So, this was an easy $5000 from each top player.
While this was extremely profitable for Supercell,
it didn’t take long for players to feel
that Supercell’s games were becoming pay
to win.
And this become even more evident with Clash
Royale.
Not only did you have to spend insane amounts
of money, but you also had to gamble a bit.
You see, when Clash Royale was launched, you
couldn’t just max out each of your cards
one by one.
Instead, you had to buy chests that gave you
a random set of cards.
So, if you wanted to max out your account,
you had to keep buying chests until the random
cards happened to be exactly what you need.
And on average, this ended up costing nearly
$30,000.
Considering this, I don’t think you’d
be surprised to hear that the vast majority
of players never played these games to the
end.
DISTRACTIONS:
Aside from it becoming virtually impossible
for casual players to max out their accounts,
we also saw several distractions appear for
these players.
While Supercell was one of the first companies
to leverage this freemium business model,
they were by no means the last.
Given the insane popularity of Supercell,
basically every game developer became aware
of this alternative mode of monetization,
and it didn’t take long for them to launch
their own offerings.
Some of the biggest competitors include Pokemon
Go, PUBG Mobile, and of course Fortnite.
Not only did these games also offer a high
quality experience for free players, but they
were arguably more fair.
Take Fortnite for example.
While you could spend tens of thousands of
dollars collecting every skin in the game,
this would give you absolutely no advantage
when it came to playing the game itself.
A pro player could start a new account and
their chances of winning would still be identical.
As these newer games started to gain popularity,
it was only natural that people started leaving
older games.
It wasn’t just newer games that were siphoning
Supercell’s user base either.
Another major culprit was social media.
When Clash of Clans came out, mobile social
media was in its infancy.
We were just starting to see apps like Instagram
and Snapchat come out.
So, the vast majority of smartphone users
weren’t using their smartphones for social
media.
They primarily used it for productivity or
gaming.
But, over time, social media has risen to
become the number 1 use of smartphones.
Many of the largest social media platforms
like Instagram and WhatsApp boast user counts
in the billions.
And as people started flocking over to social
media apps, it just became even harder for
Supercell to hold onto their users.
To make things even worse, Supercell wasn’t
just fighting against other mobile apps either.
Over the past 5 years, we’ve seen quite
a surge in pc gaming mostly thanks to AMD.
You see, in 2017, AMD launched a new series
of CPUs called Ryzen.
And since it’s release, Ryzen has substantially
reduced the cost of PC gaming.
This has prompted more people than ever to
switch over PC gaming, and this trend has
simply been accentuated by the pandemic which
forced people to stay at home.
So, in the end, many of the casual gamers
switched over to social media.
Many of the amateurs and enthusiasts switched
over to PC gaming.
And as for the remaining mobile gamers, well
they now have more quality options than ever.
CASH OUT:
So far, we’ve primarily discussed factors
that have led to gamers ditching Supercell,
but there’s also an argument to be made
that Supercell has ditched gamers. 10 years
ago, Supercell was a small gaming startup
that was trying to hit it big.
They were hungry to launch the next big game
and make their mark in the industry.
But, now they’ve already done that.
What’s the motivation to achieve something
even bigger?
Also, we should note that Supercell’s leadership
brilliantly sold the company at the peak of
their popularity.
In June of 2016, Tencent agreed to buy 84%
of the company at an $8.6 billion valuation.
While this was a great financial move for
the company’s leadership and OG employees,
this was likely not a very good move for the
company’s spirit.
You see, Supercell only had a total of 340
employees which means that the buyout was
worth $25 million per employee.
This means that unless you joined months before
the acquisition, you likely received at least
a 6 figure payout.
Meanwhile, employees that had been around
since the beginning likely received 7 figure
payouts if not multi 7 figure payouts.
In other words, the vast majority of Supercell
employees became well off if not completely
financially free.
While this is an awesome outcome for any startup,
it also drains the company of much of its
motivation.
A perfect example of this is Dell.
10 to 15 years ago, Dell was facing a relentless
decline and Michael Dell even came out of
retirement to save the company.
And one of the biggest issues that he found
was that many of Dell’s employees simply
didn’t care.
They didn’t care about the future of the
company nor did they care about being fired.
You see, Dell stock had minted 2700 millionaires
many of which were decamillionaires.
In fact, this was so common that people called
them dellionaires.
To combat this, Michael had to take Dell private,
layoff significant portions of their workforce,
and pivot to the server market.
I don’t know about you, but I don’t think
Supercell is likely to go through such an
evolution.
To make things worse, I don’t think their
parent company Tencent cares all that much
either.
While $8.6 billion is an insane amount of
money for us peasants, it’s simply a calculated
risk for Tencent.
Tencent has a market cap of over $400 billion
and that’s after crashing over 50%.
So, I don’t think they’re super motivated
to turn around Supercell either.
From their perspective, they have stakes in
dozens of gaming companies, and they just
need a few of them to do really well to make
up for such losses.
So, it’s really up to Supercell alone to
save themselves.
FUTURE OF SUPERCELL:
In the end, Supercell is one of the most iconic
and nostalgic game developers in the world.
Most of us have atleast tried one of their
games if not played them for years.
But, in recent history, Supercell hasn’t
been doing all that great.
Their trend towards pay to win has shunned
away a lot of players.
Not to mention all the extra competition they’ve
been facing from other game developers and
social media.
These issues have likely only been worsened
by the buyout which probably softened morale
and spirit amongst employees and executives.
Now, it’s not like Supercell is struggling
to make money.
They’ve introduced several sources of recurring
revenue throughout their games.
So, the remaining players are likely quite
profitable.
But in terms of returning to their former
glory, it’s really just a coinflip.
Supercell’s best bet is to just continue
launching games and hopefully one of them
will pick up steam.
But, if not, they’ll probably just end up
supporting their most popular games until
they eventually become unprofitable themselves
at which point they’ll shut these down as
well.
But, fortunately, these games likely still
have several years left before the become
unprofitable, so Supercell has quite a bit
of time to figure something out, but only
time will tell.
Which Supercell game is your favorite?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if Supercell games are nostalgic
for you.
And of course, consider checking out our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.